Musique intrigante
...
En anglais
Un téléphone sonne.
...
-Bonsoir, ici Nightline,
je t'écoute.
...
Musique douce
-Est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose
dont tu aimerais me parler ?
Elle acquiesce.
Sache que je suis vraiment là
pour t'écouter,
qu'importe le sujet.
Si tu souhaites me parler,
tu peux y aller.
Sinon,
c'est comme tu le sens.
...
On a un service
composé d'étudiants
et destinés aux étudiants.
On n'est pas professionnels.
On a été formés à l'écoute active
pour vous écouter.
...
D'accord.
Pourquoi tu ne voudrais pas parler
de tes problèmes à tes copines ?
Qu'est-ce qui te donne
envie de pleurer ?
-Nightline,
c'est une association étudiante
qui a pour mission d'améliorer
la santé mentale des jeunes,
en particulier des étudiants.
On le fait en s'appuyant
sur un outil
qui est l'aide par les pairs.
Ce qu'on fait en pratique,
c'est qu'on informe,
on déstigmatise,
on soutient, on oriente
avec tout un éventail
de dispositifs.
Il y a la ligne d'écoute
nocturne
et des formations
auprès des étudiants dans les facs.
On mène des actions de terrain,
des campagnes
sur les réseaux sociaux
et des actions de plaidoyer.
-OK, ça marche.
A toi aussi.
Merci d'avoir appelé.
Sache que tu peux nous rappeler
lorsque tu en ressens le besoin.
On est ouverts tous les soirs,
de 21h à 2h30.
Passe une bonne soirée.
Au revoir.
-Ca va ?
-Ouais, ouais.
-Je pense qu'il y a un vrai besoin
de mettre plus de moyens.
Il faut plus de psychologues
dans les services de santé.
Il y a 1 psychologue
pour 15 000 étudiants.
C'est 10 fois moins
que la recommandation
internationale.
Derrière Nightline
et la ligne d'écoute,
on veut mettre les moyens
en offrant un service disponible
pour tous les étudiants
tous les soirs.
Si on veut améliorer
la santé mentale des étudiants,
il faudrait une Nightline
dans chacun des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur.
Musique intrigante
...
-C'est le travail sans relâche,
le travail quotidien, les trajets,
la précarité étudiante.
...
-C'est des insomnies.
Forcément, quand on va en cours,
on est épuisé
et c'est...
être stressé à l'idée de tout.
On ne peut plus rien faire sans...
Sans trembler
comme pas possible.
-Dès la première année,
dès le premier cours,
les profs nous disent :
"Vous avez choisi un cursus
"très difficile,
il va falloir s'accrocher.
"Votre voisin de table
ne sera pas là dans un an."
-Des burn-out
et des dépressions
suite à, par exemple,
trop de travail
ou énormément de pression
et d'élitisme
de la part du système
de la fac, des profs.
-Je commence à détester
de plus en plus ce que je fais.
Le domaine me plaît,
mais il me consomme trop de temps.
J'ai arrêté le sport,
de voir des gens.
Je me concentre sur mes études,
ça prend beaucoup de temps.
-Les études, c'est toute ma vie.
C'est toute ma vie, je le dis
parce que j'ai des parents
qui ont investi dans mes études.
Je suis l'aînée
et j'ai trois soeurs derrière
qui me voient comme un exemple,
donc je me dis que je n'ai
pas le droit à l'échec.
...
-75 % des pathologies psychiatriques
se déclarent entre 15 et 25 ans.
Cet âge étudiant est un âge
qui peut être
particulièrement impacté
par des troubles psychologiques,
voire des maladies psychiatriques
émergentes sur cette tranche d'âge.
-Par exemple, la schizophrénie,
le trouble bipolaire,
ce sont des pathologies qui,
généralement, émergent
à cet âge-là,
donc il y a déjà une vulnérabilité
un peu caractéristique
de l'âge.
-La question de l'âge
dans les troubles de santé mentale
est fondamentale en ce sens
qu'on doit s'intéresser très tôt
à ces problématiques
pour la prévention,
l'éventuelle détection
et pour les éventuelles
prises en charge
afin d'éviter que ça se chronicise.
Ca se chronicise très bien,
malheureusement,
les troubles de santé mentale.
...
-Jusqu'à l'âge de 25 ans,
et parfois un peu au-delà,
le cerveau continue à maturer,
de différentes façons,
mais il continue à maturer,
il continue à se transformer.
Comme il se transforme,
il est particulièrement sensible
aux influences
de l'environnement.
Cette plasticité se fait
pour le meilleur et pour le pire.
...
-Ma santé mentale,
en tant qu'étudiante,
c'est la pression,
le stress, l'angoisse
de pas réussir et de pas arriver
au but qu'on s'est fixé.
-Ca a été
en deuxième année
que ça a commencé
à être la douche froide,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des profs
qui ont vraiment commencé
à nous mettre la pression
très, très fort.
-Je suis épuisé
par toutes ces années d'études,
épuisé du manque
de considération
qu'on peut recevoir
de certains professeurs.
C'est extrêmement
difficile à vivre.
-Chez moi, même si souvent,
je fais de mon mieux
et je réussis mes études,
le problème, c'est que j'ai du mal
à évacuer la pression
après les examens.
Après, je suis malade
pendant une semaine.
-Quand ça va pas bien,
je peux même
ne pas sortir
plusieurs jours.
On peut plus rien faire,
c'est anxiogène.
-J'en pouvais juste plus de tout.
J'avais un ras-le-bol
de tout le monde, de la vie
jusqu'à un point où,
malheureusement, j'ai fait
cette tentative de suicide
l'an passé.
-La caractéristique
des étudiants
par rapport aux autres,
non étudiants, c'est le cumul
des facteurs de stress qui arrivent
sur ce temps des études.
Ces facteurs de stress,
on les connaît.
Ce sont
des facteurs académiques,
notamment la sélectivité.
Ce sont des facteurs culturels
notamment pour les étudiants
assujettis à la mobilité,
que ce soit une mobilité nationale
ou internationale.
Ce sont des facteurs économiques,
la fameuse précarité étudiante.
Enfin,
le moral des étudiants
va être impacté
par l'effondrement,
on l'a vu pendant le Covid,
de telle ou telle
filière industrielle.
Musique mystérieuse
-La détresse psychologique
n'est pas une maladie.
La détresse est un ensemble,
un syndrome, un ensemble de signaux
qui peut se traduire
sur différents axes
de la vie du sujet,
évidemment,
dans la sphère affective,
émotionnelle,
avec des idées tristes,
avec une morosité,
une irritabilité,
mais aussi dans la sphère
somatique, physique,
avec des troubles du sommeil,
une fatigue intense,
une difficulté à travailler.
Dans la sphère cognitive,
c'est là où ça va impacter
le plus l'étudiant
avec une baisse
de la concentration,
de la mémorisation
et évidemment
de la motivation, qui est
le nerf de la guerre.
C'est le nerf de l'étudiant,
la motivation,
la projection dans l'avenir.
Par définition, la dépression,
c'est une absence d'anticipation,
une projection négative
dans l'avenir.
Ca va venir directement impacter
la vie étudiante.
...
-Ce qui est beaucoup plus fréquent
chez les étudiants,
ce sont des troubles
comme les troubles de l'humeur,
la dépression,
les troubles anxieux
qu'on peut retrouver
chez les étudiants,
les troubles des conduites
alimentaires qui peuvent aussi
émerger à cet âge-là
et puis, un trouble
dont on parle assez peu,
mais qui peut concerner
pas mal d'étudiants,
surtout à l'heure
où on parle beaucoup
des violences sexistes
et sexuelles,
c'est le trouble
de stress post-traumatique.
Musique éthérée
...
-Et qu'est-ce que tu en as pensé,
de ce qu'elle... t'a dit ?
...
D'accord.
Et pourquoi...
Pourquoi t'étais pas rassuré ?
Et avec tes parents,
ça se passait comment ?
...
Et tu penses qu'ils auraient réagi
comment si...
Si tu avais décidé
de leur en parler ?
...
Et ces interdits, dont tu parlais,
c'était... Ils venaient de qui ?
...
En tout cas, n'hésite pas
à nous rappeler. On est ouverts
de 21h à 2h30
tous les soirs.
Je te souhaite
une bonne soirée.
Au revoir.
...
-Mais, du coup,
je suis partie un moment.
Ca a duré combien de temps,
ton appel ?
-Euh...
Ca a duré 45 minutes.
L'idée générale de l'appel,
c'était... Ca portait sur le thème
de l'image corporelle
et de santé sexuelle,
on va dire, globalement.
C'était un peu compliqué
parce que... il était...
Il parlait toujours
de la même chose
et même quand j'essayais
de lui parler...
Enfin,
j'essayais de rebondir
sur le moindre petit élément
de son passé,
de ses parents,
tout ça, eh ben...
Il revenait à la même chose.
En fait, j'avais rien
pour me raccrocher
à ce qu'il disait. C'était...
Il me parlait d'interdits
dans son enfance
qui avaient des répercussions
à l'heure actuelle,
mais c'est tout.
J'avais pas plus de choses que ça.
Voilà. Il y avait aussi
beaucoup de silences
et j'ai eu l'impression qu'il était
plus gêné par les silences que moi,
mais... Voilà.
-Le concept des Nightline
est né
dans les années 70 à Essex,
au sud de la Grande-Bretagne,
et depuis, ça a essaimé
un peu partout en Europe
et dans le monde.
On trouve des Nightline
au Royaume-Uni, en Irlande,
en Allemagne, en Autriche,
en Suisse et en France.
On est en lien
avec des étudiants belges
pour monter
une Nightline belge.
Le problème de la santé mentale
des étudiants
n'est pas que franco-français.
Dans les pays où il y a
des études comparables,
notre constat est
d'avoir vu doubler le nombre
d'étudiants qui présentent
des symptômes dépressifs
entre avant et après le Covid,
donc on peut dire
que le concept en France,
on le retrouve un peu partout
en Europe.
Musique sombre
-Je suis étudiant en droit,
j'ai 24 ans
et j'habite
à Braine-le-Comte.
Ma santé mentale à moi,
c'est clairement pas l'idéal.
J'ai commencé à le réaliser
en bachelier, après la 1re année.
J'avais jamais dû
travailler en secondaire.
J'arrive à l'unif tout content,
je teste
mes méthodes habituelles,
et là, la première claque tombe :
je passe pas la première.
...
Franchement,
ça a commencé
avec le sommeil.
Le peu que je dormais,
c'était pas suffisant,
mon corps voulait plus se lever,
il voyait mon bureau, mon lit,
donc il y avait plus que ça,
ça travaillait constamment.
Mon corps n'arrivait plus
à faire de simples choses.
Même allumer mon PC, ça devenait
une épreuve incommensurable.
Mon corps m'a lâché.
A part dormir, j'ai rien su faire.
...
Je commence
à détester de plus en plus
ce que je fais,
j'ai plus le temps de rien faire,
plus de vie sociale,
j'en pouvais plus de tout,
j'avais un ras-le-bol de la vie
jusqu'à un point où,
malheureusement, j'ai fait
cette tentative de suicide
l'année dernière.
...
On ne nous prépare jamais
à la réalité,
en tout cas, en droit,
on vend
le succès de l'avocat à côté,
et le succès de l'avocat,
c'est un parcours du combattant.
On pousse les gens,
"ça ouvrira plein de portes",
et je vois les portes
se fermer.
Ce qui m'angoisse aussi,
c'est le fait...
Que le monde va pas.
...
-Le suicide est
un problème majeur
de santé publique pour lequel
il est possible d'agir.
On peut éviter le suicide.
Le suicide,
c'est 9000 morts par an.
On peut penser au 31 14,
bien sûr,
le numéro national
de prévention du suicide,
il peut y avoir
des dispositifs
comme les sentinelles,
des personnes, des étudiants,
des pairs aidants
repérés comme ressources
dans leur milieu
pour discerner
les crises suicidaires,
il y a les dispositifs
pour accompagner
les personnes qui ont fait
une tentative
de suicide,
en particulier des jeunes.
La prévention du suicide,
c'est la responsabilité de chacun :
le professionnel,
le bénévole, le citoyen,
le politique, le décideur.
On a tous
notre rôle à jouer.
Musique intrigante
...
-C'était un ttchat
Suicide immédiat sauf que,
quand j'ai proposé
d'appeler les secours,
la personne n'a pas voulu
et après,
elle répondait très peu.
Ensuite, du coup,
je l'ai redirigée, à sa demande,
vers l'annuaire
qu'on a,
soutien-etudiant.info,
mais après, pareil,
elle répondait très peu.
...
Ensuite,
elle m'a un petit peu parlé
des raisons qui la poussaient
à vouloir mourir.
Après,
elle n'a plus répondu.
-Et...
tu te sens comment
du fait qu'elle ait plus ou moins
arrêté de te répondre ?
-Bah...
Ca m'a pas mal inquiétée
pendant le tchat
parce que, forcément,
mon esprit me disait :
"Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Est-ce que, ça y est,
"elle va plus répondre ?"
...
Ca peut arriver
que les personnes nous parlent
de suicide et, dans ce cas,
ça va attirer
notre attention
et on va proposer, par exemple,
d'appeler les secours.
Quand on appelle les secours,
on est obligés de briser l'anonymat,
mais on va prévenir
l'appelant ou l'appelante
qu'il va y avoir
une rupture d'anonymat
parce que, si on n'a pas
les informations nécessaires,
les secours ne peuvent pas
intervenir,
donc c'est le seul cas
où il y a
sortie d'anonymat.
Musique douce
Chant des oiseaux
...
-Je suis ici depuis...
presque une semaine.
...
Première chose que je fais, c'est
d'aller au poste des infirmiers
pour prendre mon traitement
du jour et, très souvent,
c'est aussi mon 1er contact social.
...
-Bonjour !
-Bonjour.
Bien dormi ?
-Ca a été, oui.
...
-C'est assez ?
-Oui.
-La clinique Fond'Roy
est un hôpital psychiatrique
à Uccle, dans le sud
de Bruxelles, et l'unité 1,
dans laquelle je travaille,
est une unité dédiée
aux jeunes adultes
entre 18 et 30 ans.
Il y a plusieurs types
de pathologies
qu'on peut rencontrer ici :
les 1res décompensations
psychiatriques,
qui peuvent être
des bouffées délirantes,
des tableaux dépressifs,
des crises suicidaires,
des addictions importantes
qui les mettent souvent
en retrait de la société,
en repli chez eux,
et tout ce qui est
crise existentielle,
crise de sens,
crise familiale aussi
qui fait qu'à un moment, ces jeunes
qui n'ont pas de logement,
trouvent ici un "asile",
même si le mot
est un peu galvaudé,
mais un asile où ils peuvent
se poser, se reposer,
dans un endroit
un peu neutre
pour repenser un peu
leur projet de vie.
Musique grave
...
-Je fais des études de droit
en bachelier
et je vais être diplômé,
alors, en 2024.
...
Je pense que mes études ont eu
un impact sur ma santé mentale,
absolument.
Moi, personnellement,
j'ai tout remis
en question,
même mes études,
en me disant :
"En fait, je sais même pas pourquoi
je fais ces études."
A force de rester seul,
on commence à se dire
qu'on va pas forcément savoir
réussir ces études aussi. Enfin...
Il y a eu plein
de questionnements.
A un moment donné,
je voyais juste que
seulement avoir
une psychologue
et avoir des séances,
des consultations,
prendre une pilule
chaque matin
n'était pas suffisant.
Je voyais vraiment qu'il y avait...
J'avais besoin d'être...
dans une institution,
pour retrouver une hygiène de vie,
qu'on me mette vraiment
une structure,
une routine
et qu'on se focalise là-dessus,
que ce soit une pause
dans la vie parce que
c'est comme ça que je le vis
car j'ai l'impression
que ma vie
est en pause et que,
à ce moment,
on est juste
en hôpital,
hospitalisé
et on pense seulement :
"Comment je me sens
aujourd'hui ?"
et je voyais vraiment
que c'était nécessaire
parce que,
si je ne rentrais pas,
j'allais faire quelque chose
de plus grave.
Je ne sais pas
si je me sens
forcément mieux,
mais je dirais
que je me sens plus en paix.
Ce que j'espère,
c'est...
d'avoir pris le temps,
justement...
d'aller creuser en moi,
d'aller voir, en fait,
d'où viennent
tous ces traumatismes.
J'essaye de faire un équilibre entre
les deux, ma santé et mes études
et, du coup,
je pense que c'est vraiment
mon premier objectif,
de pouvoir franchir ce cap-là.
Je pense que,
en sortant d'ici,
je ne vais pas être
100 % guéri
ou à 100 % de nouveau...
en forme
ou quoi que ce soit,
mais je pense que, du moins,
il y aura quand même
quelques petits trucs
que j'aurai réglés,
des choses qui seraient
plus claires pour moi.
Musique grave
...
-Je m'appelle Margot,
j'ai 26 ans
et j'ai fait
une licence de japonais.
...
J'ai passé plusieurs mois
au Japon
et ça a été un déclencheur
pour moi
pour commencer une fac de japonais
et reprendre les études
après ça. Du coup, je suis rentrée
et la première année,
j'étais absolument passionnée
par tout ce que j'apprenais,
je travaillais avec plaisir,
je restais jusqu'à 21h
à la bibliothèque
et je sortais
avec un grand sourire
et c'est en deuxième année que ça
a commencé à être la douche froide.
...
Il y a des profs
qui ont vraiment commencé
à nous mettre la pression
très, très fort.
Il y a eu ce côté
extrêmement compétitif
qui a été mis en place
et il y a des gens
qui ne supportent pas ça du tout.
J'ai littéralement
fait une dépression
et un burn-out car je n'arrivais
vraiment plus à suivre,
je n'avais plus de vie
et je le vivais mal,
ce qui n'était pas le cas
en première année.
J'en ai parlé
à un de mes profs référents
que j'appréciais beaucoup,
à ce moment-là.
Je lui ai dit
que ça n'allait pas
et il m'a répondu,
assez sereinement :
"Ah, dans tous les cas, en L2,
"il y a 15 % des étudiants japonais
qui sont en dépression. On le sait."
...
Tous les ans,
il y a plusieurs suicides.
Ils ne s'en vantent pas,
mais on le sait quand même.
Je me dis que je suis fière,
justement, d'avoir réussi
à passer au-dessus de tout ça
parce que tout le monde
n'a pas cette chance.
Musique grave
...
-Bonsoir. Ici Nightline.
Je t'écoute.
...
OK.
Et c'est quoi, exactement,
ton problème de santé ?
D'accord.
...
Oui.
Oui, je comprends.
C'est le simple fait de sortir
qui te met KO ?
Ou c'est
ce que ça engendre,
c'est-à-dire le déplacement,
tout ça ?
...
Mmh mmh.
-Comment tu t'es senti ?
-Euh... Ca va, ça va.
Il y avait un rapport
très bienveillant, donc bien.
C'était quelqu'un de touchant,
de très gentil.
L'appel n'a pas duré longtemps,
une trentaine de minutes
parce qu'en fait, elle avait juste
besoin d'exprimer...
De parler de sa situation. A la fin,
elle l'a dit, que c'était...
cathartique de pouvoir juste
sortir les informations de sa tête,
de les transmettre
et de pouvoir passer à autre chose
parce qu'elle souffre
d'une maladie
qui lui pourrit la vie.
-Mmh.
-Du coup,
elle se retrouve très seule.
Elle avait besoin d'en parler.
-OK.
...
-Le mal-être étudiant
est très ancien. Les différentes
enquêtes épidémiologiques
menées par les mutuelles étudiantes,
puis par l'Observatoire
de la vie étudiante,
ont montré, avant le Covid,
20 % de détresse psychologique,
puis 25 %
de détresse psychologique
du fait des cumuls
de facteurs de stress.
Tous ces facteurs-là contribuent
à la détresse universitaire
qui n'a pas été prise en compte
suffisamment
par les pouvoirs publics.
Depuis le rapport Wauquiez,
qui date de 2006, finalement,
rien n'a été vraiment mis en oeuvre
de manière importante
pour la santé étudiante.
Il a fallu attendre
notre gouvernement actuel
et le séisme du Covid
pour que des moyens substantiels
soient délivrés
au regard d'une souffrance
qui est montée
jusqu'à 43 %
de détresse psychologique,
en juin 2021,
septembre 2021 encore,
donc largement au sortir du Covid.
Musique pesante
...
-La crise du Covid,
on sait, a été particulièrement
vulnérabilisante
au plan de la santé mentale
pour la population générale,
pour les jeunes en particulier.
Elle a fait un peu
un effet loupe.
...
-Il y a véritablement
un avant et un après mars 2020,
dans la mesure où...
...les étudiants en particulier
et les jeunes en général
ont été très sévèrement impactés
par la crise Covid.
La privation de socialité
chez les jeunes,
dont chez les étudiants,
c'est quelque chose
de cataclysmique.
C'est un moment où on construit
sa vie relationnelle,
où on en a besoin.
On a généralement
beaucoup de relations, de sorties.
On va dans des lieux présentiels
pour avoir des cours,
des formations...
Avoir supprimé tout ça,
ça a eu un impact absolument énorme.
Musique pesante
...
-Comme tout étudiant,
je pense que mes études
ont beaucoup d'influence
sur ma santé mentale.
Il y a beaucoup de stress,
il y a beaucoup de doutes,
non seulement
pour mes études actuelles,
mais pour ce qu'elles me permettront
de faire plus tard.
Pendant la période de Covid,
le plus dur,
je pense que ça a été vraiment
l'isolation.
C'était vraiment le moment
où on est seul avec soi-même.
Donc, mon premier confinement,
je l'ai vécu...
Je l'ai vécu dans ma chambre.
...
Pendant cette période,
je ne suis pas sorti.
J'ai acheté beaucoup de Lego.
Je ne suis pas sorti du tout
à l'extérieur.
Pas du tout.
J'étais vraiment seul.
...
Cet isolement a pesé
sur ma santé mentale,
parce que ne sortant plus
et prenant moins soin
de moi,
il y avait des moments de doute,
de se voir dans le miroir...
Quand on n'est pas bien,
on se voit encore plus laid
que ce qu'on est réellement.
Ca a énormément joué
sur ma santé mentale
de rester enfermé,
de ne presque parler à personne,
parce que
même si j'avais quelques amis
à qui je pouvais envoyer
des messages,
ben ne sortant pas,
je n'avais pas grand-chose à dire,
et on fait vite le tour
d'une journée, enfermé chez soi.
...
En été 2021,
suite au deuxième confinement,
ma meilleure amie, elle,
a vécu la crise du Covid
encore beaucoup plus fort
que n'importe qui, je pense,
dans mon entourage.
Elle a préféré faire une bêtise
et quitter ce monde.
C'est une jolie façon
de le dire, mais...
Elle avait beaucoup de doutes,
c'était une période très difficile,
où elle s'est sentie très seule,
où je pense qu'aucun message virtuel
n'aurait suffi.
Je pense
qu'elle avait vraiment besoin
que la vie soit
comme elle était avant,
de sortir,
se changer les idées,
mais elle est restée chez elle,
elle a broyé encore plus de noir.
C'est cette période
qui l'a enfoncée.
-Les étudiants dont la socialité
a été complètement supprimée,
de même que la possibilité
de se projeter dans leurs études,
ont véritablement vécu ça
comme un traumatisme.
Un traumatisme,
c'est-à-dire quelque chose
qui effracte le psychisme
et qui est susceptible d'attenter
à la vie, ou en tout cas,
gravement à la qualité de la vie,
et ça devient difficile
de se projeter dans l'avenir.
Donc, les étudiants, les jeunes,
ont, davantage que d'autres
catégories de la population,
ces états
de stress post-traumatique.
C'est une chose inédite
dans l'histoire de l'humanité.
L'état de stress post-traumatique,
ça survient
quand on risque de mourir,
quand on voit quelqu'un mourir,
qu'on est pris dans un attentat...
Là, on a des gens,
toute une population
qui s'est retrouvée
dans cet état traumatisé
en raison
des confinements qu'ils ont subis.
On le sait parce qu'ils le disent.
Quand on leur demande
"qu'est-ce qui,
dans ce qu'il s'est passé,
a été le plus traumatogène
pour vous ?",
Il y a la peur de mourir,
que les proches meurent,
et le risque
d'un prochain confinement.
Musique pesante
...
-Je m'appelle Amina,
j'ai 24 ans,
étudiante en sciences politiques,
à l'université
de Versailles Saint-Quentin.
Ma santé mentale,
en tant qu'étudiante,
c'est la pression, le stress,
l'angoisse
de pas réussir
et de pas arriver
au but qu'on s'est fixé.
Il y a eu beaucoup de stress,
beaucoup de pression,
la première année.
La seconde, il y a eu le Covid,
et là, c'était vraiment
très compliqué de suivre,
parce que du coup,
on est isolé, on est seul,
on n'est plus dans l'élément
qu'on est en train de construire.
Il y a eu le premier confinement.
On était terrorisés par le Covid.
On se rendait compte
de ce qui se passait,
que le Covid, c'était grave,
qu'il fallait s'isoler,
mais très rapidement,
on était surchargés
par beaucoup de travail à la maison.
Les profs nous mettaient
la pression.
En étant à la maison,
je pense qu'ils pensaient
qu'on ne faisait rien,
alors qu'on avait
une double charge.
C'était très compliqué
sur ma santé mentale.
J'ai eu un début d'ulcère
à l'estomac.
J'ai passé parfois des semaines
sans vouloir me lever,
sans vouloir faire quoi que ce soit,
et avoir la pression de me lever
et de travailler pour réussir.
On se dit
qu'on n'a pas besoin d'aide,
que la seule solution,
ce serait de réussir
pour aller mieux,
et on met de côté
tout ce qui nous arrive
en ce moment même.
-Ils ont été beaucoup stigmatisés.
Ils ont été désignés
comme un des éléments majeurs
de la circulation virale.
Donc, ça a eu un effet terrible
sur leur santé mentale,
qui s'est très rapidement vu
dans les données.
On a vu exploser
les troubles anxieux,
les troubles dépressifs,
les troubles du sommeil,
tous les jeunes, tous les étudiants
qui se sont retrouvés
avec des troubles mentaux de ce type
en raison de cette période
risquent d'en subir les conséquences
pendant très longtemps,
du simple point de vue
de la santé mentale.
Par ailleurs, pour beaucoup,
leur cursus de formation
a été très gravement altéré.
Et ça aura un impact
sur toute leur vie.
On a engendré des conséquences
pour plusieurs décennies.
On peut pas du tout considérer
que le problème est terminé.
Malheureusement, on pourrait
considérer qu'il commence.
-Il y a forcément
des appels qui restent,
à des degrés différents.
Nous, à Nightline,
on a des moyens aussi différents
de pouvoir les extérioriser.
Le premier niveau,
c'est ces débriefings
qu'on fait à chaud,
tout de suite après avoir raccroché
ou dans les minutes
qui suivent
et qu'on partage
avec les autres bénévoles
en permanence avec nous.
Ca, c'est un peu le premier degré
d'extériorisation.
Ensuite, on a ce qu'on appelle
"les réunions de partage",
c'est des réunions qui ont lieu
une fois par mois
et qui rassemblent
entre 5 et 10 bénévoles
et qui sont encadrées
par une psychologue.
Pendant ces réunions de partage,
l'objectif,
c'est justement
de parler de ces appels
qui restent avec nous,
parce que les thématiques
sont lourdes
et qu'elles nous ont marqués,
parce qu'on s'est senti
en difficulté pendant l'appel,
pour X raison...
Ces réunions sont obligatoires
pour tous les bénévoles
qui prennent des appels.
Elles sont mensuelles.
On n'a pas le droit
de prendre des appels
pendant un mois
si on n'a pas fait sa réunion.
En parler à la famille et aux amis,
c'est justement pas possible,
chez Nightline.
Le rôle de bénévole est anonyme.
Cet anonymat est au premier plan
pour les appelants.
Eux ne doivent pas dévoiler
d'information sur eux.
Elle est valable aussi pour nous,
nous, les bénévoles.
On ne doit pas révéler
à notre entourage
qu'on est bénévole à Nightline.
C'est une partie de notre quotidien
qui reste secrète
pour un tas de raisons.
L'une d'entre elles,
c'est de ne pas projeter d'identité
sur ce bénévole
qui peut nous répondre
sur ce service d'écoute,
pour ne pas décourager
certains proches
qui pourraient avoir envie
d'appeler,
mais qui ne le font pas,
car ils auraient vent
de notre engagement.
Donc, pour ces raisons
et pour encore plein d'autres,
on ne peut pas partager
ce qui se passe en permanence
avec nos proches.
Musique pesante
...
-C'est un microcosme, ici.
Dans la vraie vie,
ça peut pas se passer comme ça.
En tout cas, de mon côté,
ça ne se passe pas comme ça.
Ma journée est faite.
Je fais ce que j'ai à faire,
et j'ai pas le temps
de m'occuper
de ma santé mentale.
-Parfois,
on va pas trouver
la personne à qui parler
ou se sentir en confiance,
et ça aussi...
Personnellement, j'ai beaucoup
de mal à parler de moi,
surtout quand ça va pas bien.
C'est dur
de faire parvenir le message
de "là, ça va pas,
j'ai besoin d'aide".
-La société a échoué à fournir
suffisamment de ressources.
S'il y avait plus de choses
en ambulatoire,
ça permettrait de maintenir
son rythme de vie, son emploi,
tout en ayant une place
pour prendre soin de soi,
et que ce ne soit pas
de l'ordre du sacrifice.
-C'est super dur,
à l'extérieur.
J'ai tenté...
Ca fait trois ou quatre ans
que je tente de faire ça
qu'à l'extérieur
et je n'y arrive pas.
En tout cas, en psychiatrie,
c'est bouché de chez bouché,
complètement.
Donc, il y a cette réalité-là aussi.
Ce n'est pas que le bon vouloir
de la personne.
On est fatigué émotionnellement,
on n'a pas envie de s'en sortir
parce qu'on est dans une boucle,
mais en plus, si tout est bouché,
c'est pas possible, quoi.
...
-C'est un sentiment
très particulier.
C'est pas tous les jours
qu'on va chez quelqu'un et qu'on dit
"ouais, moi, en fait,
j'ai envie de mourir"
ou "j'ai pas l'énergie
"pour aller faire mes courses,
pour me lever",
et que l'autre dit :
"Ouais, moi aussi, franchement..."
Ce sont vraiment des sujets
qui sont hyper...
Enfin, pas hyper,
mais on les entend pas très souvent,
dans la vie de tous les jours.
Ici, on arrive à en parler
entre patients,
et c'est complètement normal.
Moi et ma génération,
on se pose énormément de questions
sur l'avenir,
et du coup, on est pleinement
dans les études.
Avec le réchauffement climatique,
on sait même pas
comment le monde va être
dans 30 ou 50 ans.
Ca crée vraiment
une grosse anxiété, quoi.
une crise existentielle
de se dire qu'on est en train
de faire des études
et de se demander
si ça vaut vraiment le coup.
L'anxiété, elle est là, quoi.
-Quand on dit "écoanxiété",
on parle de trouble anxieux,
et ça risque d'avoir la conséquence
qu'on va considérer
que si les jeunes sont écoanxieux,
c'est qu'ils ont
des problématiques propres.
Non, les jeunes,
et toute l'humanité, développent
des émotions par rapport
à ce risque
qui sont légitimes,
qui sont saines,
et qui,
lorsqu'elles ne deviennent pas
inhibantes parce qu'elles sont
trop intenses,
génèrent de l'action, de la colère,
de la révolte.
Ca devient de la peur,
parce que l'anxiété,
c'est quelque chose qui est là
par rapport à un danger incertain,
et là, c'est un danger concret.
C'est de la peur.
Quand on n'a pas peur
face à un danger,
c'est qu'on est inconscient.
Musique douce
...
-Je m'appelle Zinedine.
J'ai 24 ans. Je fais un Master 2
de droit
à l'université Paris Nanterre.
On va dire que je vais très mal,
parce que je suis épuisé
par toutes ces années d'études,
et c'est extrêmement difficile
à vivre.
Tous les jours,
je me rends à la fac
la boule au ventre,
je vais à mon alternance
la boule au ventre.
Les études,
ça apporte personnellement,
mais il y a une forme de déception
au bout du tunnel,
parce qu'il n'y a pas de transition.
On finit l'université,
puis on est balancé
dans le grand bain,
et on se rend compte
que c'est pas vraiment
ce qu'on nous a présenté au début.
Je pense personnellement
que je ne suis pas fait
pour le monde dans lequel...
on me balance aujourd'hui.
Il y a un contexte
qui est très particulier.
Il y a eu la crise Covid,
il y a eu même le mouvement
des gilets jaunes.
On pourrait l'inclure.
L'inflation, la guerre,
toutes ces choses
qui sont difficiles à vivre.
De manière plus générale, ça pèse
sur toute la société,
mais les étudiants,
ils ont une difficulté
supplémentaire,
c'est qu'ils sont déjà,
pour certains,
dans une grande précarité.
En plus de cela,
ils doivent rester motivés
pendant leurs études.
C'est le plus difficile,
rester motivé
alors que l'avenir est
totalement incertain.
-C'est plus dur de se projeter
aujourd'hui
qu'il y a
une dizaine d'années
parce que les problématiques
sont plus mises en avant.
Le réchauffement climatique,
c'est devenu un sujet quotidien,
les problématiques
économiques aussi,
le chômage,
les violences
sexistes et sexuelles.
Il y a un climat ambiant
qui est probablement
plus anxiogène aujourd'hui
pour les jeunes
et qui est accentué
par la pression des examens,
l'isolement de la famille.
Faire des études, c'est bien,
mais on a besoin d'aller plus loin
dans comment on se sent bien,
où on veut aller,
beaucoup plus
que gagner un gros salaire.
C'est aller bien
dans ses études
pour aller bien
dans sa vie professionnelle.
Les étudiants et étudiantes
ont envie d'avoir
un bon cadre de vie
avant d'avoir
un cadre de vie luxueux.
-Les sociétés sont
éminemment régulières,
fiables, structurées, prévisibles
pour leurs membres,
donc évidemment, quand on s'engage
dans des études,
on s'attend à ce que le métier
auquel on se forme
existe encore
dans 5 ou 10 ans,
quand on projette
une famille,
on s'attend à ce qu'il y ait
encore une planète dans 15 ans
et ce sont des régularités
puissantes et structurantes
non seulement
de la société,
mais aussi
des psychismes individuels
et tout ceci
a été disloqué,
et donc, les jeunes sont
pris dans ça aujourd'hui
à une époque de leur vie
où leur psychisme,
leur fonctionnement relationnel
et leur implication dans la société
sont en construction,
donc il y a cette dimension
de "ça va se construire
sur quelque chose
"de pas stable
et de pas prévisible"
et là, c'est la base des graves,
graves, graves troubles mentaux.
Musique intense
...
-J'ai 21 ans et je suis actuellement
en 2e année
de BUT carrières sociales,
parcours animation sociale
et socioculturelle,
et l'IUT de Tourcoing.
...
Alors, la santé mentale,
c'est... compliqué
selon les jours.
Il y a déjà tout ce qui est
vie quotidienne.
Ca veut dire, quand on est
étudiant et précaire,
savoir comment se loger,
payer le loyer,
payer tout ce qu'il y a à côté,
les frais quotidiens
comme tout ce qui est transports,
la nourriture,
les courses, etc,
plus, après,
quand on n'a pas de soutien
de sa famille proche,
comme les parents,
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
à gérer au quotidien.
...
Avec mes parents,
ce qui s'est passé,
c'est que je suis LGBT et eux...
ils ont... pas bien pris la...
La nouvelle
et du coup,
ça fait trois ans,
à cause de ça,
que je ne les vois plus
et que je n'ai pas le droit
de voir mon petit frère.
...
J'avais aucun revenu parce que
j'avais pas le droit à la bourse,
donc j'ai dû demander
une pension alimentaire,
même si ça a été long
parce que, ben, vivre
quand on est étudiant,
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
sans ressources
financières
et c'est vrai que,
quand on peut pas,
en étant étudiant,
être suivi par un psychologue
parce que ça coûte cher
et qu'on voit les délais
pour les bureaux d'aide
ou pour, des fois,
les psychiatres
qui peuvent être remboursés
par la Sécurité sociale...
c'est compliqué. Des fois, on a
tendance plus à ne pas être suivi
et à laisser tomber parce que
c'est épuisant, en plus des études,
de devoir chercher, de devoir
s'investir encore sur un autre plan.
C'est décourageant
et déprimant.
...
-En France,
on a des vraies difficultés
autour de la santé mentale
en ce sens que,
dans les centres
médico-psychologiques,
il y a des listes d'attente
qui sont importantes.
Par ailleurs,
les services de santé universitaires
ne sont pas assez pourvus,
notamment, en psychologues
ou en professionnels
de la psychiatrie.
-Les files d'attente, aujourd'hui,
pour les jeunes,
que ce soit en ville,
à l'université,
dans les services
universitaires, à l'école,
les files d'attente
pour accéder
à des soins psychiques,
elles sont lunaires.
C'est 6 mois.
Dans certains endroits en France
très défavorisés,
c'est 18 mois.
Autant dire
que ça n'a aucun sens.
Quand on a un problème
de santé mentale sérieux,
même pas forcément sévère,
mais déjà sérieux,
c'est tout de suite
maintenant.
Musique douce
Brouhaha
Il toque.
...
-Ca va, patron ?
-Ca va bien et vous ?
-Ca va, ça va.
On dit quoi ?
-On dit rien.
-Y a rien ?
-Ben non.
-OK. Allez !
T'as pas encore rangé ?
Eh là, eh là, eh là ! Et quoi ?
T'as la flemme, c'est ça ?
-Non, je faisais une sieste.
-Ah ! Allez, à tout à l'heure.
-A tout à l'heure.
Il toque.
C'est Michel
pour le tour de 16h.
Ca va ?
-Oui.
-Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui ?
-Euh... Pas grand-chose.
-Comment ça, pas grand-chose ?
T'as pas fait d'activité
aujourd'hui ?
T'as pas été en activité ?
-En fin de journée.
-Fin de journée ?
-Ouais.
Il se racle la gorge.
-Il est 16h.
-Ouais, je vais voir
mon père d'abord.
-Ah, d'accord.
Papa d'abord et l'activité après.
-Oui.
-Mmh !
Ca va. C'est bon.
Allez, à tout à l'heure.
-A tout à l'heure.
Il toque.
...
-On va rentrer quand même.
Oh oh...
Ca va, maman ?
Il pousse
ce qui bloque le passage.
La chaise grince.
Là, la demoiselle,
elle dort,
mais il faut quand même vérifier
qu'elle respire.
Musique douce
...
-Je m'appelle Oumy, j'ai 25 ans,
je suis sénégalaise.
Je suis venue en France
après mon bac, en 2017,
je suis partie à Tours,
où j'ai fait des études de droit,
et là, je suis revenue sur Paris
pour continuer mes études.
Ma première année à Tours
a été éprouvante parce que
je ne connaissais pas la ville,
c'était la première fois
que j'ai commencé
à vivre seule,
à aller faire mes courses,
à payer mon loyer,
et entre l'université
et ma vie sociale,
j'étais vite fatiguée
et il a fallu que je me retrouve
aux urgences,
que le médecin me demande
ce que je faisais dans la vie,
que je lui dise
que j'étais
étudiante en droit et que
j'avais pas envie de me réveiller
pour que
je me rende compte
de ce qu'est en train
de devenir ma vie.
J'avais pas envie de me réveiller,
c'était compliqué
entre la fac,
ma vie sociale,
enfin, j'avais l'impression
d'être sur tous les fronts
et que j'avais pas de résultats.
J'ai pris des médicaments
et j'ai pris 20 kg.
Ca ne m'a pas aidée.
Ca ne m'a pas aidée
parce que derrière...
Enfin, on perd confiance en soi,
on ne se trouve plus belle,
mes habits
ne m'allaient plus,
tout le monde me disait
que j'avais pris du poids
comme si je ne me voyais pas
devant la glace chaque matin.
Si un Français
doit être bien,
l'étudiant étranger
doit être excellent
pour s'en sortir
et on est constamment
sous pression,
donc il va falloir allier...
Il va falloir
réussir ses études.
Si on ne réussit pas,
la préfecture ne va pas renouveler
ton titre de séjour,
et derrière, il faut avoir
une vie sociale,
il faut trouver
un logement décent,
il faut manger à sa faim,
voilà, il faut vivre,
tout simplement,
alors que vivre a un coût
en France.
Vivre, c'est pas évident.
Il y a "vivre" et "vivre".
Il suffit pas de respirer
pour dire qu'on vit.
-Quand on est étudiant
et qu'on ne va pas bien,
on n'est pas seul.
C'est un point important.
On a certes dit
qu'il y avait
des difficultés,
des listes d'attente
et pour autant,
les professionnels sont mobilisés,
et donc, les étudiants
ne sont pas seuls.
-Il y a des initiatives
qui ont été mises en place,
des étudiants et étudiantes
pour les étudiants
et les étudiantes,
et c'est vers ça
que nous, on pense
qu'il faut aussi
encourager
ces initiatives-là,
aider les structures à se monter,
à aller dans la bonne direction,
puisque l'Etat et l'université
ne peuvent pas
combler tous les manques.
Ca coûte énormément d'argent,
mais les étudiants et étudiantes
ont envie de se mobiliser,
d'aider
au quotidien et parfois nuit et jour
pour certaines activités.
-Tu t'imaginais
que ça se passerait comment ?
C'est quelque chose
qui te dérange ?
Musique douce
...
Je t'en prie.
N'hésite pas à rappeler
si tu en as envie.
...
Je t'en prie.
Passe une bonne soirée.
Merci. Au revoir.
...
-Tu veux débriefer,
du coup ?
-Yes. Euh...
Du coup, ça a duré deux heures,
donc le temps maximal.
C'était... Y a eu plein
de thématiques qui ont été abordées.
Y a eu la dépression...
les relations familiales
suite à un coming out...
et... le regard des gens
par rapport à la dépression,
du coup,
dans la thématique
et que, en fait,
la personne pouvait pas...
Enfin, ne se sentait pas
légitime
de dire à ses proches
qu'elle avait une dépression
et du coup, j'ai appris
qu'il y a des gens qui sont pas...
Enfin, qui n'ont
toujours pas conscience
des enjeux de santé mentale
et que oui, ça existe
et que non, c'est pas des fous.
Ca m'a fait vachement de peine
parce que c'était
une personne
qui avait une histoire
assez lourde
de par la réaction de sa famille
face à son coming out et tout,
donc c'était pas...
Enfin, ouais,
j'étais un peu triste
pour cette personne,
mais la personne était contente
d'avoir pu parler,
donc c'était chouette.
Elle m'a dit à la fin
qu'elle comptait
recontacter Nightline
parce que ça l'avait aidée,
donc ça fait plaisir.
-Parfois, on a l'impression que
les jeunes ne veulent pas s'engager
ou ne font rien pour la société,
on l'entend beaucoup.
Nous, on voit plutôt l'inverse :
une vraie volonté de prendre acte
que tout ne va pas bien,
mais on n'a pas envie d'être
la génération d'après.
Il y a un besoin,
chez les étudiantes
et étudiants, de se dire :
"On est acteurs, actrices
"déjà maintenant. On se rend compte
qu'il faut agir et on agit."
-De manière générale,
même s'ils sont en difficulté
dans leur vie actuelle,
ils ne sont pas dans une vision
catastrophique du monde.
Ce sont des jeunes
qui restent très engagés
dans un avenir sur lequel
ils ont le sentiment
d'avoir les moyens
d'intervenir
du fait de leur formation,
de leur alliance
avec la science,
de leur niveau d'ambition,
du fait de leur vitalité,
et je pense
que cette vision décliniste
est assez loin,
c'est plus une vision
de leurs parents ou grands-parents,
mais c'est loin
de leurs préoccupations du moment.
-Ils sont vraiment
dans une envie d'agir
et ils agissent déjà.
On n'a plus l'idée
de "on fera plus tard",
mais vraiment "on sait faire,
"on a fait des choses.
"Maintenant, il faut
nous laisser la place",
ce besoin d'avoir une place
qui leur soit considérée
et qu'on ne leur dise pas :
"Vous ferez plus tard",
mais ils peuvent faire maintenant
et ils en ont envie.
Musique pop
...
Musique éthérée
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...